even though I play basketball if I watch
Like an ultra or a marathon I'm looking
at what you're doing
but I'm thinking about you know you had
to wake up early to train for this like
everybody see the finished
product but a lot of people don't think
about right the training that went into
it people don't realize how hard it is
to be good at anything but it's tough
the one word that I know my son probably
hates to hear and the word is details
we're working out in the gym and we're
shooting shots and my son will put his
foot on the line right shooting a
three-pointer but if your foot is on the
line it's a what it's a two yeah right I
don't even look to see if it went in
first I just looked to see if his foot
was on the line
and if he make it I'll be like don't
count he
and I'll be like details everything
matters not saying that you did it on
purpose or anything like that but it's
those little details that yeah that
matter